[Music]
in bloody basement news I heard about
this will happen what happened was
submitted by pubes for eyebrows I've
told you before right
I mean whether or not go they don't
really thick hair on my eyebrows
eyebrows look beautiful keep it
sometimes when I pluck it it's so
[ __ ] thick my whole ugly worried that
but it doesn't have the to bring chorus
they're like really [ __ ] to wrinkle oh
god those are some coarse ass okay yeah
you have to fill them in don't have to
fill them in that's crazy feel my
eyebrows I should soft this boy hey hey
you went the wrong way
it's like a [ __ ] brillo pad it feels
almost like it's like a cat oh [ __ ] it's
not like a cat oh my god that's like my
nose hair yeah it's beard it's beard
hair you have whiskers on your eyebrow I
really don't know dark her because her
eyebrows like from here it's this long
going she calls this like a slicked back
hair I thought it was just the whole
thing yeah my pubes are soft so I you
know like oh your ears you know that
means you cook I got mad you poked an
eyebrow
you could comb it down or coming up and
she's kind of crazy does any do any
cultures braid their pea beer I don't
know TIFF cube expert like a Samoan
maybe or something some [ __ ] like that
Samoan pubic hairs here we go okay I
think he's asking you personally like
you should have the information I'm
looking in the informations direction a
family's basement flooded with animal
blood from a neighboring meat locker
they said five feet or five inches 5
inches right that's a lot of blood in
this article they don't tell me how oh I
was listening a ki littile
an ikemen in being every morning that's
a local radio station k-rock shutouts
good I love Kevin to me the money and
then they said that my head cuz um but
yeah so we should just collect it and
make blood jello mmm but it's dirty
already it's on the floor and actually
filter that mother yeah actually like it
ruined a lot of the things that the
family had in their basement and also
they're in they're in the process of
trying to sell that house
oh that timing ever so they do well the
location is pretty bad true okay exactly
so they live next door to a meat locker
and so apparently this meat locker
location they were butchering animals
and they were having the entire blood
and like chunks of meat like I don't
know train things the words are not
coming out so animal pieces they they
were down the drain and so it ended up
like flooding the basement of their
neighbor because they share the same
piping oh and and yeah so now this is
all destroyed other pictures but very
good pictures but it doesn't look like a
haunted house in there some [ __ ] baby
chicken oh Jesus that's a lot yeah
somebody had their period the house had
a period shining bro wait go back go
back to that picture
I like there's one bottle of bleach that
they try to do a witness why they're
crying one bottle of bleach dude
I know right like dude that's like you'd
think a horror movie happen in your head
yeah this shining dude yeah if you don't
have an explanation for a while you're
thinking some [ __ ] up [ __ ] go on
please no I heard too that the meat
locker company was also like hey that
wasn't us has nothing to do with that
right does it have who's whose is it
there's [ __ ] blood your lady's
problem where the plumbing whatever the
[ __ ]
true like in the video article or like
the video that's in the article they
were saying that but then in the written
part of the article they're saying that
they had always to took responsibility
for and they're being very compliant and
they're saying that they intend to help
pay and clean up or like help pay for
the cleanup class oh that's good and so
they're saying quote we don't want to
harm anybody we're not bad people we're
trying to make a living not enemies and
so they're saying that the company is
hoping a resolution can be reached out
of court 200 years ago this family would
have been killed as witches
oh yeah if this happened dude uh was it
listening to like Kevin B little k-rock
yeah maybe it was it's a local radio
station shut up to them and I think they
were saying like back in the day when
they had like the salem witch trial and
all that [ __ ] you know how the glass has
condensation and then you put it on the
table and you know sometimes it's like
yeah they like hung a chick because it
did that neighbor they said she was a
witch why she's reaching for its lid a
little bit yeah yeah I like you know it
just slides on its own they're like you
rich holy
I like how they go you know what if you
drown then you're safe because you're
not a witch but if you stay alive then
you're a witch so we're gonna drown
that's so stupid
if I was that girl it's like fine take
me whatever you guys are [ __ ] idiots
I'll see you in the next life and you
never come back she drowned oh she
wasn't a witch yeah what's it wait
what's the angle to that again it's like
if she's innocent she'll float if she's
is a witch she's gonna survive in you're
like oh no if she dies you're like okay
she wasn't a witch is tell the truth
at least there's like no I did [ __ ] whoa
damn now what do you do yeah yeah goes
off up top because I would have just
been like oh you know what um I'm
actually Jesus's friend see don't I hold
on a second all Jesus's friends are dead
you're a witch see how they work but
they never tried that none of them tried
it because if you're gonna if you're
about to go die anyway you might as well
be like go with
Oh try some [ __ ] I was here said by God
like no wonder you have magical powers
oh yeah and then you [ __ ] escape what
if there really were witches Joe you
never thought of that we actually caught
them and kill them I want instead of
saying you're Jesus is friend you say
you're Jesus oh yeah dummy that's
gambling too huh yeah a woman come on
alright Jesus coming back as a woman I'm
married I'm Mary Magdalene what do you
think of that that's worse is it this
you have a bad rap yes she was a
prostitute I wouldn't know how I don't
know how to I wouldn't know how to get
out of this [ __ ] like imagine being I'm
so it's a game of mafia with nothing but
it is yeah oh I mean we'd pull that
already Jackie party we pulled some
stupid-ass moves you're been on their
life can you imagine though this [ __ ]
happened all over the world oh man I'm
so happening oh that's true yeah true
aren't we lucky [ __ ] dude I'm so lucky
like where does it happen Oh backwards
ass country yeah a lot of developing
nations something like that kind of [ __ ]
there are which you're dying today
mmm like your which we think you're a
which are going but now modern-day which
it's like you're a racist or you're a
misogynist or you're whatever is they
cancel people's yeah they publicly shame
them and all that and it later it finds
out that they were like whatever yeah
everybody tarnished Obama just spoke out
against woke culture today to Joshua
Obama basically he was like hey guys
instead of trying to nitpick everything
and call everybody out for every little
thing it's not doing anything like he
was basically saying what culture needs
to chill out
yeah and this like little speech he gave
he's like do what I did with African
countries bomb the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
them see that's too real sir we're
liking Obama right you're right you're
right okay
everyone like president after the term
is done yeah true it's funny like
everyone just forgets obviously not like
a bush and Ellen why thank God thank God
though because [ __ ] man I was I was like
man everyone's like in George Bush
because he's given it [ __ ] candies out
them a lot of like that didn't know [ __ ]
they like they like Bush is looking like
a limp a cute little grandpa yeah cuz
he's looking like an uncle and [ __ ]
exactly the old guard is coming down but
that was what he did smart low he was
like I'm just dumb how I [ __ ] go to
war with everybody and get oil money
it's too real Caesars make it fun than
Tim G's okay but you know people do
enjoy when we do that and talk about the
real [ __ ] well the way they here's more
the way that your hair stuck up it was
very witchy yeah well what did Sam like
that's a threat I think she put a spell
on us you ever practice witchcraft in
high school as a board
yeah that should always work they work
scary bro yeah what is it what is it oh
it's when you lay down like your friend
lays down and then everyone surrounds
this person and then you have two
fingers and you're trying to lift them
by saying why does it work
what like levitates I don't know man
okay I've had I've seen other people do
it different ways there's 20 people
don't want to live no but I don't know
what happens or I don't know if it's
like a psychological thing or what but
even without the light as a feather
stiff as a board [ __ ] one time I was at
this I was on a shoot and this guy was
like yo let's do this alright everybody
trying um lifts up somebody with just
like you know just doing this right and
he was sitting in a chair it didn't work
and then we're all doing it and then it
goes okay now everyone like put your
hands over their head but don't touch
hands let's all focus our energy and
[ __ ] right
and we all did it and we lift them that
easy but what you didn't see was your
friend
on the left you missed that part oh yeah
there's this Netflix show called mind
games or something and it's like a kid's
thing where they teach you like how your
brain [ __ ] with you pretty much and
this one episode was like about like
scary things and how your mind plays
tricks on you I got to watch that and
then they did this they did this this
one thing where they had people sit
around this table and around the Ouija
board and they're saying like never mind
I'm not watching it you can't do it Lee
explains why a Ouija board works and so
at first they were saying like oh you
know is so-and-so here or whatever and
like everyone without knowing they are
actually moving the [ __ ] thing II
watch it no so then but they their
brains are tricking them into thinking
it's paranormal because there's always
one [ __ ] troll that's what you get a
certain so they're not intentionally
moving it that's the thing for sure so
then they ended up blindfolding every
every archetype and then they're like
they're all they're still asking
questions to this supposed ghost which
is this girl's grandpa or something more
scary so the whole group ends up moving
the thing but it literally lands in
nothing cuz they're not they can't see
it's still moving because they're they
think that it's a parent that it's an
actual good experiment no it's still the
devil and I'm not gonna mess with it
it's not the guy Brujeria party and
that's what I said it works that's good
I don't like that show which genre is
one of my favorite Halloween porn style
[Music]